hey everybody Sean McGuinness here with
the GS news update this weekend on
Twitter Phil Spencer the head of Xbox
gave some hints about what we can expect
from Microsoft at e3 Spencer said he
wants Microsoft's e3 2014 showing to be
more fan focused and they'll be focusing
on hardcore gamers hardcore hard cold
when asked if gamers can expect new IPs
announced at the show Spencer replied
yes we'll announce both new IP and new
sequels at e3 one fan asked on Twitter
if there's any chance of a handheld
gaming device from Microsoft
Spencer responded I don't think we'll do
a dedicated handheld gaming device
rather just focus on Windows Phone and
tablets and maybe with controller
support someday in regards to Halo
developer 343 industries Spencer said he
was under strict orders to not talk
about any IPS that they're working on he
also said that there should be some
interesting information leading up to e3
he said yeah you'll get a couple of
things before May should be a good month
for news and although he didn't say that
there would be info at e3 he did say
external storage is still in the works
and to watch the monthly updates for
more details so what do you want to hear
Microsoft announced at e3 let us know in
the comments below and stay tuned to
game spot for all year III 2014 updates